mise à part ce tracteur au loin c'est le
calme plat dans ses vignes de mennetou à
quelques jours des vendanges il n'y a
plus grand chose à faire si ce n'est
attendre et goûter quelques raisins
francis audio passe une à deux fois par
semaine sur ces parcelles et pour savoir
où il en est pas besoin d'outils
scientifiques
juste quelques pépins de raisin pour
garder pépins commencent déjà à être
bien bras d'après il suffit de les
croquer et donc quand on a un petit goût
de noisette comme ça ça veut dire qu'ils
sont bien mûres là on a encore un petit
peu d'astringence même très très peu
grâce au soleil cet été la maturation
des raisins est bien avancée et les
pluies de la semaine passée ont permis
de revigorer la plante
résultat la vigne il termine son travail
dans les meilleures conditions
là on voit qu'elle respire qu'elle est
en bonne santé a fait de la
photosynthèse et nourrit bien le raisin
si on avait des fortes chaleurs
l'acidité diminué assez vite et puis l'
équilibre sucre acidité n'est plus
forcément là vous avez beaucoup de sucre
moins d'acidité d'inca vin qui peut être
plus lourd mais là le fait que les
températures se rafraîchissent là c'est
vraiment bénéfique pour que le raisin
finissent par mourir tranquillement
ici aussi on surveille l'évolution du
raisin mais de manière plus scientifique
taux de sucre ph acidité
tous ces chiffres l'indiquent les
vendanges 2015 sont précoces 10 à 15
jours d'avant ce un phénomène plutôt
rare mais positif c'est la garantie d'un
bon vin oui toujours
parce que on est sûr que le raisin mûrit
bien que la maturité va arriver à son
terme
on est sûr que même si on perd un petit
peu de temps parce qu'il fait plus froid
même si on perd de trois jours de toute
façon le raisin mûrir à bien et donc on
aura la finesse aromatique l'equilibre
qu'on recherche
mais pour goûter ce millésime il faudra
attendre 2016 ou bien retrouver quelques
bouteilles de 2003 et 2011 deux années
où les vendanges avaient là aussi des
marées exceptionnellement tôt